Donald Trump's approval rating has
imploded Gallup does daily tracking poll
of presidential approval they've been
doing it for a very very long time
president Trump's job approval rating
hit a new low over the weekend 40
percent 55 percent disapproving
approving rather these results are based
on a three-day rolling average and
Trump's approval ratings have been
kicked tick ticking down slightly a
little bit at a time since he assumed
office you'll remember at the beginning
of his presidency he had a 45% job
approval rating up from the just pre
inauguration level of about 38 37 % the
committed trumpets only believe
information that supports Trump's
amazing popularity Trump has already
said if there's any polls that are bad
about me they're fake news the reality
of course is that only about 25% of the
population voted for Trump I suspect
that there is quite a low floor for what
Donald Trump's approval rating could
ultimately be and when Trump led in the
polling all he talked about were polls
and when the polls aren't good we saw
this during the run-up to the election
and we're seeing it now as his approval
rating all of a sudden it's not an issue
now as a reminder
let me put up the graphic that that I
used a few days ago it took Donald Trump
only eight days to get to 50%
presidential disapproval you'll remember
that over 700 days went by before Ronald
Reagan got to 50% disapproval over 1,300
days for Bush 1 and 1,200 days for Bush
2 it took President Obama just under a
thousand days to get to 50% disapproval
and Bill Clinton getting to 50%
disapproval for the first time after 573
days 8 days 8 days
for Donald Trump to get to 50%
disapproval you know the most shocking
thing to me about this poll tap that 4
out of 10 people in the country approve
of the job that Donald Trump is doing
what do you approve of it honestly seems
rather high and I think if Donald Trump
continues to abuse his power and make
all these mistakes I think that number
could be cut in half relatively soon
yeah I know I've talked for a very long
time how there's a
contingent of the country that will
support the president no matter what and
there's a contingent of the country that
will disapprove of the president no
matter what and the in-between is sort
of where elections are won and lost
it's where the approval rating of a
president can go up or go down remember
25 percent of the country voted for
Trump this is a very unusual situation
that we're in and I agree with Pat that
Donald Trump's approval rating could go
way lower before it bottoms out if you
had to guess will the Michael Flynn
Russia connected resignation hurt
Trump's approval rating or will it be
sort of a non-factor no I don't think
it'll be a factor because I mean I think
people who are willing to be swayed on
whether they approve of Trump or not
aren't into the weeds enough to even
know who Michael Flynn is you think I
mean it's been headline news for the
last 12 hours or so although I agree
with you that there's a big contingent
which just doesn't care Oh Trump's
connected to Russia or he's not Michael
Flynn what does he do who was he anyway
I mean my connection stuff definitely I
mean if that gets more exposure I think
that could hurt him significantly yet
Michael Flynn specifically not so much
interesting yeah I think I think I tend
to agree with you if the Russia angle is
what sort of perceived as the main story
that could have an impact but Flynn
specifically although the general sense
that it's chaos and everything's falling
apart that could hurt Donald Trump what
I want to dig into tomorrow or the next
day is has Donald Trump actually done
anything tangible in the three weeks
that he's been president there's
differing differing opinions about that
and we're going to dig into that in the
next couple of days